the gift taken relationships I think I
am naturally on a scale from one to ten
one being a taker and ten being a giver
I'm naturally a ten and tens get run all
over ones don't get opportunities
because they're always just trying to
take and people just get tired of them
the vast majority of people are tit for
tatters so you give I give just like the
fives and I think that what happened
over my career is that I shifted from a
10 to like an eight they've actually
done a lot of game theory research on
this and found that like 8 out of ten is
the proper amount of give take for
optimal outcome you just have to know
when it is your turn to take